I don't know if this is gonna show up on
the camera but as chocolate stains last
time I let my kid get snow caps at the
movies The Incredibles - so I have now
seen it I as I alluded to it took my
daughter so I was really nervous going
into this the the entire concept of a
sequel to The Incredibles which honestly
I had no it kind of technically ended on
a cliffhanger but it didn't really it
was a pretty complete experience start
to finish and I was nervous about the
very concept of a sequel then I saw the
first trailer I was like oh god this
this looks like it could be really bad
and having now seen the movie it's
pretty good it's not as good as the
original I don't I'm not sure anyone
actually expected it to be but most of
the stuff that I was really nervous
about based on the trailer actually
worked pretty well that's not to say
that everything worked there are some
issues and an out I'll get into the but
I'll start just by picking up on the
stuff that I was really nervous on based
off the trailer say I didn't like that
it was looking like things were gonna be
all mr. mom with with mr. incredible at
home taking care of the kids while his
wife was out so that plot actually works
pretty well partly because it does not
eat up nearly as much screen time as I
was afraid of it's very much the B plot
and it's screen time is reflective of
that so that helps if they put more
emphasis on it than it had that that
really could have heard it but the other
thing was is that it's not just about
him learning logistically how to handle
his kids he also has to actually grow up
in mature a little I would argue more
than he did in the first movie he
actually has to confront the fact that
he's kind of a selfish prick
which in a way this this movie deals
with head-on without ever feeling like
they're having a key on other characters
sit down and let
show him what a jerk he is but like
early on he encourages his wife getting
involved in super heroing again so that
it can improve the the reputation of
supers which means he'll get to super
hero again so he wants to support his
wife so that ultimately he gets to
benefit he doesn't he's not it's not
about supporting her in the abstract so
between that and sort of realizing what
he needs to do in relation to his kids
to get this working better he does
mature as a character a surprising
amount
I actually kind of got to tip the hat
I'll do it literally to to the mr.
incredible storyline and it also had
most of the the better humor jack-jack
despite you know the surprise of all his
powers being gone what's still good for
some good slapstick super-powered
slapstick and you know it's it's just
it's fun and it's funny and it's amusing
it was definitely some of my daughter's
favorite stuff what was was the
jack-jack stuff the other two kids
violet feels like she gets the short
shrift although I think she's actually
got more of a plot going on than - but
in an odd way I feel like that almost
hurts her more - doesn't really have a
subplot of his own but the thing is he
doesn't need one he's you know he's
there doing his thing when it's
appropriate for him to do it they try to
actually give violet a subplot and it I
don't know it just never feels like it
comes together and then there's a lot of
kind of oddities about this film one of
them is that I had actually forgotten
that the family didn't see Jack Jack's
you know explosion of powers and at the
end of the first movie only Syndrome did
and he he died so suppose for
Incredibles one I guess but the rest of
them didn't see and I in action that
hadn't really occurred to me that they
didn't realize he had power
but then when mr. incredible sees him
exhibit powers fairly early on into the
movie I'm like oh that's right they
didn't know but then he doesn't tell
anybody so we keep getting it's like
every half hour or so another set of
characters find out that this kid has
powers and all these characters are
going he has powers yes I'm like what
can we just get everybody on the same
page cuz we as the audience have known
this for the last 14 years and then we
have to continually keep watching the
cast catch up I guess is supposed to be
a running gag but there isn't really a
joke there it's just a really long just
very drawn-out process of everybody
finding this this one pieces of
information out another thing that was
really weird there was something off
about the look of basically every
character who wasn't a repeat from the
previous movie and it took me a little
while to like I'm watching going
something's just not quite right about
these designs about these faces and what
I realized once Evelyn the character of
Evelyn showed up and I saw everyone oh
my god she looks like she's from a
DreamWorks movie and that's when it hit
me they went with all the new characters
slightly less stylized versus the very
angular very stylized look of the
characters in the original so the repeat
characters still have that because
obviously they need to look the same as
they do before but all the new
characters they're slightly angular but
by and large most of them are more
realistic like not photo realistic but
they have more touches to them to try
and make them look quote-unquote like
real people and it results and just they
look like DreamWorks characters they
look like the human characters from
aliens versus monsters or Megamind
and it just looks weird I don't know if
I'm alone in that I can't think of
anybody else having mentioned anything
like that so maybe I'm crazy
I probably crazy I may not be crazy
about this though so so that that was
that was the other thing and I know that
sounds nitpicky but aesthetically it
kept bugging me um a fair number of
people are at least critics have cited
the villain as being a weakness I don't
think that's actually true the villain
is not as good as syndrome cuz syndrome
was a brilliant villain you know really
good in and of himself and also super
thematic for what was going on the
villain here is it works is functional
kind of has a cool gimmick going on and
and when we get into motivation set the
degree to which like the origin for this
villain is brought down to like a single
moment and the amount of sort of blame
put on specific elements of that I think
push a little too far cause up until
that I actually thought the villain had
a decent enough point and actually some
of the things that go on with the
villain in a way kind of I don't want to
say deconstruct but sort of feel like at
least to a certain level they are
addressing some of the sort of latter
day criticisms of the first film that
have come up it's in that the original
film has a little bit of an Objectivist
philosophy this one feels like it's
critiquing that position a little bit
which feels nice oh another thing that I
thought was gonna be terrible was Edna
coming back I was looking forward to
that at all Edna mode was one of the
highlights of the first film but I was
so parent I'm like this is gonna be one
of those characters that you brought
back because she was funny the first
time but there's gonna be no reason to
bring her back it's gonna be a total
retread and on paper that's true but it
just kind of works in terms of how they
sort of ignite
her interest as a character it actually
works so I was kind of impressed by that
I think the other thing that's the real
major strength of this is the action
scenes the they do some really inventive
stuff especially with Elastigirl they
really do show how cool a power set that
can be when done properly we also get a
much better variety of superpowers on
display because it's not just the the
recurring characters we get introduced
to a whole bunch of new characters with
a whole new sets of powers and some of
them are just cool some of there are
neat powers in and of themselves and
then even ones that seem like oh that
seems kind of basic then get used in
pretty neat ways so I props them on that
as well but I think the other thing and
I I had this thought of my own but I
have to I I feel like I have to bring
this up because I was there with my
six-year-old it's a little long and a
little draggy movies almost 2 hours long
and about an hour into it my
six-year-old asked me how much more is
there that's usually not a good sign and
my kid was enraptured all the way
through a wrinkle in time so you know
she she can handle long movie she can
handle even things that aren't like
non-stop action but she was it was kind
of stretching it a little bit for her
and I think it I think it is a little
longer than it needs to be but overall I
I would call this one a pleasant
surprise I went in I've really started
to dread him sequels to films that
didn't feel built for it like I look
forward to you know Marvel Cinematic
Universe movies because every movie that
they make is designed with potential for
the next one that's not to say that
every film that does that always works I
cite Marvel because I think they still
tell pretty complete stories but also
you leave very obvious room for further
growth you know building something for
the sequel nothing else that's how you
get amazing spider-man 2 but you know
with something that is that feels like
it's a complete story and it
doesn't inherently warrant a sequel and
it didn't really lay groundwork for
sequel which I feel is the case for The
Incredibles I've gotten really nervous
about those kinds of sequels these days
they they can be really really painful
and I this didn't hurt and I don't feel
it tarnished the original either so I I
would call it a win it's not amazing but
it's good so I'll end it on that note
have you seen The Incredibles 2 what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do like and subscribe and
find me on Twitter and patreon and the
podcast when and if I get around to
doing something with that I'm working on
it
I wait for all that stuff and more is
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]